ميرا مراتي المسؤوله عن فريق مكون من سته
اشخاص كانوا وراء ثروه العالميه تعمل في
شركه اوبن اي المطوره لروبوت الدردشه منذ
عام 2018 مراتي التي ولدت في البانيا
غادرت في سن السادس عشر للالتحاق بالجامعه
في كندا في 2013 التحقت بشركه تسلا لتطوير
طراز اكس وتوظيف الذكاء الاصطناعي في
السيارات ذاتيه القياده عام 2016 كانت
مسؤوله عن المنتجات والهندسه في شركه ليب
موشن التي كانت تعمل بنظام الواقع المعزز
واستبدال لوحات المفاتيح وماوس الكمبيوتر
بايماءات اليد على الجانب الشخصي تملك
مراتي ذوقا فنيا شبيها لمجال عملها فمثلا
فيلمها المفضل هو اسبيس اوديسي التي تدور
احداثه على القمر وكوكب المشتري واحد
الشخصيات الرئيسيه هو جهاز كم بيوتر لديه
ذكاء اصطناعي ويتحكم بانظمه المركبه
الفضائيه اما اغنيتها المفضله فهي
بارانويد اندرويد التي انتجت في
التسعينيات وتصور حياه البشر في القرض 21
بطريقه سوداويه حيث الانفصال عن المجتمع
والتوحد مع التكنولوجيا على حساب التفاعل
البشري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]